up to a cat clinic in Madrid for a
demonstration that you should definitely
not ride home it's almost like they just
took the cat and press pause you can
literally see how the cat's demeanor
kind of changes it's it's a little bit
nervous and apprehensive and then this
clip goes on and immediately you just
get this huh yes this cat deactivation
is real but should only be done by a
veterinarian so how does it work this is
called pinch induced behavioral
inhibition or clip gnosis when a small
pressure is applied to the back of the
cat's neck
it causes partial immobility in fact it
makes sense when the mothers the cats
are carrying their kittens they want
them to hold still
and how did they carry them in the back
of the neck they grab them and carry
them around so when the vet puts the
clip on the back of this cat it has the
same response it had when it was a
kitten and his mother picked it up it
relaxes okay but how does a clip make a
cat catatonic scientists aren't entirely
sure how but a parasympathetic nervous
response is initiated and this basically
means that the heart rate slows down the
blood vessels become dilated and it
essentially contributes to the relaxed
state of the cat this cat is absolutely
fine
scientists have actually studied fitness
and looked for signs of pain and there
haven't been any having said that these
cat is being handled by a trained
veterinarian so please don't try this at
home with your cat if you press too hard
or in the wrong place you could damage
the counter